what's up reject nation we got ourselves
a
trailer for the tim's story directed
tom and jerry john did you grow up on
tom and jerry
i sure did various episodes all the
complex mythology
oh no way that's great to hear because i
didn't see
i'll take care of the nerdier stuff you
take care of the kids
and jerry and scooby-doo let's do it
that's my expertise i have a child of
hearts
[Music]
oh cool it's not some cgi crap
animated it or at least
did it to look like duty
say it does look like albert in the
chipmunks
oh sweet that makes me happy yeah
so four presidents three folks two kings
chloe grace
oh wow
we have a mouse problem
oh wow this is so detailed
we can leverage millions of years
a picture of this insta book face or
ticky talk
we will be moved
this looks so fun
ken jones
i think i might have just pulled this
off
[Music]
rob delaney rob delaney yeah that's what
it is
of course
no warner brothers must have bought that
from acme
[Music]
oh interesting
i have seen some of tom and jerry
jerry you've seen most tom and jerry and
the only thing you maybe missed is the
dog that sometimes enters the picture
this is this hannah barbera oh
don't quote me but i think baby all
right let's keep that in the video
actually but um
i you know as someone who's only seen
snippets of tom and jerry when i was
really young i've seen some episodes
when i was like a little little kid as
most of us
did probably i was actually pleasantly
surprised to see that they
kind of did a little bit more of the
space jam roger
roger rabbit route where they made them
animated and it says warner brothers
animation at the top it's not
some like cgi smurfs looking
or even the scooby-doo live action or
alvin and the chipmunks which is what i
thought we were going to be walking into
with this so it was nice to see that
it's actually
animated even though it's taking place
in real life honestly like
for this this is exactly the kind of
movie i expected it to look like when
you say live action tom and jerry where
you're gonna
slap in some human characters here's a
little plot that you don't really
probably care that much about it but
you're going to
fuse a human story onto the side of it
to make it a real movie
yeah because you know that's the cat and
mouse game between them so how do we
build a plot that has some stakes around
it
and it's about as generic of that as
you'd expect
at the same time i'm not really bothered
by it because it's almost exactly what
i'd expect and it looks
fun to me it looks like a charming movie
and the cast is good too
glory grace moretz looks great michael
pena doing some
jokes that will one day be outdated ken
jong's really funny kim jong recently
retweeted me i won't say on what tweet
but he recently did
and um also uh uh rob delaney
you know this it's a funny cast i'm sure
there's gonna be some pleasant
funny stuff that happens in here you
know and i'm also one of the guys
who didn't hate like the first alvin in
the chipmunks movie too
okay which i'm not saying this is the
same thing but i'm saying i'm not always
perturbed
or put off by this i know some fans are
but as far as it stands i mean this
looks like it's honoring
uh the spirit of it and the chaos and
tim's story
while you know his name is really
associated with those first two
fantastic four movies
he's done some comedies that i think are
hilarious i mean he did
the shaft movie didn't he yeah the most
recent one i thought the movie was so
funny
it was really funny he did the
barbershop films i think tim's story is
actually a really talented comedic
director
so as much as this trailer wasn't
mind-blowing it sold me on that this is
going to be a really fun time and i'm
not just being polite like this is my
honest feeling
generic sure fun yeah to me i i pretty
much left this trailer thinking this
could go
one of basically two ways i don't see it
falling in the middle either this is
going to be kind of excruciating or like
surprisingly charming
and in keeping with the slapstick
craziness of tom and jerry because that
was the thing that
as much as yes there is a lot of stuff
that you would expect this trailer to do
in terms of the
familiar human story we are in a time
now
where cartoon violence is a bit more
under the microscope and so for me as a
kid who grew
up on yeah those old looney tunes and
different things it's nice to see that
tradition of slapstick perhaps coming
back um and so yeah like this again
looks like it's teetering it could
easily be a painful mess but i feel like
it has the potential to have yeah a
charming fun
human story and i do like the uh just
based on the charisma of the actors
basically
just like if i like this ensemble enough
together that'll work and then with tom
and jerry i do think it's cool that they
went with
i think this is probably done on a
computer but with that
hand-drawn aesthetic in mind like it's
a little bit 3d it has more 3d texturing
on it which i think is interesting and i
would be
curious to see how that plays across the
whole movie because yeah i do
like the idea of as long as we're going
to do a tom and jerry movie why don't we
take that tradition of a space jam
or or roger rabbit which is a much
better movie than that and uh
yeah do the 2-d-esque quality in our
real world and treat them as though
that's just how they look
and uh yeah i i would be curious to
check it out on that
alone i can see a lot of people's
childhoods uh freaking out over this but
you know
i mean it it looks like it could be
playing it looks fine
i mean i i also think though the human
plot
looks a little bit kind of crazy
it looks like there's a ton going on
yeah
because in the in the other movies that
we might have referenced it's kind of
like a simple
plot and then the animated characters
show up and kind of create some annoying
interruptions for them right
and then here this this looks like chaos
at the hotel at the the hotel looks
insane
of you got chloe grace for rats who's
obviously the lead of this it looks like
her career is on the line
and then you got this wedding coming up
so they're setting up all these events
and then you got mean boss or one who's
like cons
you know conspiring against them you
have a lot
to basically set up to go into
catastrophizations
yeah there's a lot of craziness
happening that could either be a good
thing or a terrible thing
at this point but i like the fact that
it seems like they're putting in some
effort
to the human side of it it looks like
they're actually trying to just not
oh he's someone who works at a newspaper
and something goes we have some stupid
thing like that it looks like they're
actually trying to create some type of
like let's really take advantage of the
hotel setting and
let's whip up as much craziness among
the people as is usually whipped up
between
tom and jerry and i think the movie will
basically live or die by the way that it
is able to intermingle those things
because this
trailer felt like we're doing tom and
jerry craziness and then we cut away to
this human thing that vaguely relates to
them and i hope the movie has a bit more
cross potential to justify itself
basically yeah
that's how it'll work well we'll see how
it goes guys but we know it's the stance
it's all right sorry yeah
tom and jerry what do you think leave
your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button
the rogue 808 jt jt buddy you've been
an incredible friend to us for such a
long time with it being thanksgiving
season
i do want to say a special thank you for
everything you've contributed this whole
this entire time i've gotten to know you
you've been very generous with offering
up your passions your dreams your
ambitions giving
feedback whenever i've asked for it
you've always given wonderful
recommendations and i missed the times
we used to do all those google hangouts
but i'll forever be grateful for those
memories because you just let john and i
talk the whole time
and you just primarily laugh at the dumb
stuff we'd say yeah
says brainstorm yeah and sometimes we
came up with some great ideas from just
letting a spitball while you just watch
that system i legitimately think back
and miss those times chatting with you
buddy
i miss you dude and i hope you're doing
well hope you're staying safe with your
family down hawaii you'd be safe brother